we are indeed with Sam Savion who got a
tremendous Victory under his boat Sam
first of all take us through the game
all right
um well he surprised me in the opening
with this rare line with Bishop before
checking A5 I think I played relatively
well with Bishop G5
although there are many ways to get a
slight Advantage here Bishop E7
yeah this is a critical moment because I
have many ideas I can take this Knight
on F6 and play Knight C3
which either he has to play Passive
position with D6 or play D5 which is not
really an ideal
GT structure maybe this is how I
actually had to play yeah id5 yeah I
think I should have played like this
because uh I played Queen C2 yes and he
played interesting with Knight A6
with the idea of Knight before or C5
somewhere
I'm pretty sure this is wrong with the
special effects of 69 G5 but
uh maybe A3 first and after C5 I should
do it
take on F6 now Bishop takes F6 yeah
because now I can take his net on A6 at
the end
I think yeah now this is very nice
because he doesn't get benoni now with
Ed B5 because opponent C5 is hanging
very important I have D6 have A4 and you
go A4 right beautiful position for
weight
um very nice instead I went for this
immediately and the drawback was that I
loved night before
after Bishop takes B7
now there's no more Knights no no I
can't capture tonight yeah C5 still it
feels like you so it should be better
advantage in the position
is a mistake I think you should play
etxc first and after C takes D now he
gets a banoni bishop F6 t6b5
what if uh what if you try not to worry
I can't try this yes no he's not on
before
um
I'm actually curious can you play B5
instead of D6 perhaps yeah that's a good
point
B5 and what if you try to go this yes
that now I can try to go this is very
interesting or A4 first is also
interesting after B5 A4 first yeah
these things just feels visual I guess
to try to operate depend only structures
uh and if you take now D6 is that the
point or
I'm not sure it's a very complicated
position here but it still feels like
you're harboring some hopes or an
advantage I think it's a little better
here at this point okay because he loves
this 1955 idea and if he takes on B2
which is
uh let's see Rook B1 Bishop goes back I
go E3 and now it's now the move A5 is
really bad because the pawn on B6 is
extremely weak I can play along the D
file attack to d-pawn so you're a pawn
down but actually you're better you're
much better yeah because I have a risky
attack on the king side whenever I want
to start yeah I think it's objectively
maybe winning here close to winning yeah
wow and he played this move B5 let's
reactivate his this is correct yeah but
I think I played perfectly rookie one
and queen C2
C3 he was really trying to give the pawn
back yeah
27. maybe yeah I'm not super
really no I think you played well I I
think you definitely there's one note
where I'm not sure about yeah this is
fine I like Queen A4 yes yeah Bishop
Rook D3 maybe here
right so what the engine was saying is
that you have to take advantage and
capture the B file the control of the B
file as fast as possible Queen B3 and
then Rook to B1 yeah this is nice yeah
yeah definitely and now you have
everything once I get the people it's
pretty much over yeah go Bishop D5 C4
Queen B7 if you want
and just to interrupt it for a second
Jeffrey's game did finish with a draw
against Darius zverch
nothing unexpected in that one let's
continue with the analysis and so I
played Rook D3 and after G6 now I just
now notice that I can attack this go
move along the B file but now it's a bit
Shaker because what happened in the game
so I tried Bishop Q also another reason
this is probably worse is because I
allowed H5 H4 ideas and he was also
playing Super Quick at this point I
think he's trying to put some pressure
on it I think he was trying to play
against the clock yeah did you feel any
pressure building up at this point or
did you feel the position is simple
enough for you Rook D3 that way that
feels impressive extra time I would
probably find queen queen B3 rugby one
yeah yeah now yeah this is a very nice
idea for him Rook design Rook B2 I
really don't know how to play here I
checked like every thinking F1 Bishop D5
Bishop E6
um
maybe I should go take the policy six
but yeah also he didn't have that much
time to check out right right yeah only
eight minutes at this point you spend
six of them on this movie I I realized
that I can always get tunes with Rook
Cafe Rook of stone which is nice
yes very nice I did this a few times
gained some time
I think you're he kind of panicked with
Bishop you want this is also a draw but
H6 was much safer in my opinion because
F4 let's say A4
F5 captures captures A3
and now I can't go F6 because Bishop
takes F6 Rook takes in Rook B2 let's see
and the one is one going
you cannot you're not in time to defend
I do have a fight you'll see that but
Bishop he just stays here yes yes no way
to make progress I guess
he didn't see F4 idea
I think this was a cute idea if you go
G5 just recruit
it's again this with C4 that ruined it
and uh it's just running
um and he played Rook to f8 of course he
saw that you gave her another check F4
gained a couple of tempies I think
everything he did correct here yes just
he didn't see the
is H5
H5 here H5 is also move H4 Rook F2
this might be okay too yes based on the
same idea with Rooker yes okay
and actually uh at this point he had
another opportunity
after um F5 yes he must play G1 check
uh I think what he missed was King F3
Bishop G5 King F2 and he has Rook G4
here yeah yeah this is why we thought
that he missed as well probably did you
speak with him after the game yeah yeah
he did miss this and after that after
you pick up uh but his main Miss was in
the game that I Bishop F7 at the end of
the line yeah yeah yeah Bishop to F7
because the point is Rook F2 doesn't
actually threaten anything which is nice
I just moved my Rook away and there's no
Rook F1 check anymore yeah
very nice game Sam congratulations you
start off the U.S Championship with a
bang how do you feel about your chance
is what is your motivation in this event
uh well I had a really good event last
year and I'm definitely trying to build
on that especially with two extra rounds
uh there are more chances for decisive
results so do you feel that helps you
the extra two rounds because of your age
let's say I think so I mean we'll see
how it goes at the end but I'm happy
that there are many runs in this
tournament absolutely more rounds more
chess congratulations Sam and we'll see
you tomorrow thank you uh Sam a question
for you if you don't mind as a
competitor in the US Championship are
you annoyed that uh events uh the
cheating scandals are overshadowing the
tournament you're not just concentrating
and focused on
the beautiful national championships
that we have I mean I'm never annoyed by
these things in general it's happened
before an open tournament and I just
kind of block it out and concentrate on
the chest fair enough a great answer
thank you Sam and good luck in the rest
of the tournament thank you absolutely
and there was one one game remaining
Anastasia